day one i'm in the interior of the vast
pennsylvania wilderness
i've brought with me only the bare
essentials
a knife a roll of duct tape
in case i need to fashion a shelter or
make some sort of water vessel
it's hot today the sun is in the
two-thirds
easterly quadrant which would make it
about
two o'clock in the afternoon really
beating down on me now
i think that i want to get a little more
comfortable
because the sun is depleting my
resources
okay that oh there we go
watch that i don't hit my corroded
artery
here i lied to michael i said that i
would leave him alone but i will not
i will remain close by to provide unseen
moral support
but i will never help him i will let
harm befall him i will even let him die
but i will never let him lose his
dignity
there we go much better now everything
i brought with me can be used
my sport coat here can be fashioned
into a backpack of sorts
i'm going to wear what was once
one of my pant legs
see this is a beautiful piece of
material this can be used for all sorts
of things
some sort of kerchief
keep my neck nice and comfortable i am
totally alone right now with only my
thoughts
i love it i'm loving it
i can literally say anything i want no
one
is going to hear me wish i could have
gone with ryan on that cool retreat
janet has plastic boobs i
have hemorrhoids
doesn't even matter michael is a man of
great depth and
passion i don't know what he's searching
for out here
i hope he finds it
lunch
about two more minutes
and take a look at this i tented my
pants
i've made myself a nice pants tent
shelter and this little guy may be
dunder mifflin paper someday
nothing to worry about just using the
scope safety is
on so it's on our schedule mr swanson
we have one activity planned not getting
killed
boys i'm trying to teach you something
about nature and self-reliance
nothing beats hard work and
determination
is this the pawnee goddesses i've got
the puppies you ordered oh
the puppies for the puppy party that
we're having in our cabin those puppies
what is that smell that is the absence
of urine
you got to leave brooklyn to get that no
urine i could get used to this
oh yes and that's just the beginning my
friend just waited you're sitting
fireside
sipping on a premium chinese scotch and
smoking a sweet rwandan cigar
okay okay i probably could have done
without the countries of origin but that
sounds great
yeah what else do you have planned oh so
much i'm talking fishing i'm talking
poker i'm talking
frisbee boyle what else am i talking
wildflower picking so we can make our
own cologne nope i was talking bonfires
and s'mores but that's my fault for
throwing to you
this is gonna be fun as hell this is
gonna be the best weekend
ever welcome to puddle manor
stink puddle manor
well i don't really go camping ever
jerry so i'm not gonna spend 150
on a tent just gonna sleep on the floor
it's called the ground
when it's outside whatever i know we'll
never be soul mates but
we're friends now get in this boat and
read some boring french poetry
i i've never actually done this before
this is this is a theoretical fantasy
how do you roll a boat fishing relaxes
me
it's like yoga except i still get to
kill something
and just as you have planted your seed
in the ground
i am going to plant my seed in you
i think you know what you're saying
smells pretty bad doesn't it
uh-huh it's called bull crap and a
client can smell it from a mile away
gotcha okay everyone shut up
and look at me welcome to visions of
nature
this room has several paintings in it
some are big some are small
people did them and they are here now i
believe that after this is over they'll
be hung in government buildings why the
government is involved in an art show is
beyond me
i also think it's pointless for a human
to paint scenes of nature
when they could just go outside and
stand in it
anyway please do not misinterpret the
fact that i am talking right now as
genuine interest
in art and attempt to discuss it with me
further
end of speech should you be our manager
i wouldn't let her manage a celery farm
those who can't farm
farm celery fine i'll talk to you
but you got to follow me i got to go
feed the hogs oh my god what are you
gonna feed them is it us
corn oh corn maze as there was at the
first thanksgiving jake right let's go
talk
oh this is pungent out here so weird how
food smells so good but farms smell so
bad
yeah i think that every day it's really
important to me that april loves camping
so i
went ahead and set up the ultimate
campsite
love nest complete with beautiful
starlight we got champagne
also rose petals as you can see they
smell terrific
hey where are you i'm here where are you
we're inside the main entrance near the
sign that says pawnee campground
oh i'm in a totally different place
that's why we can't see each other oh my
god andy i don't even want to be here
the air is too fresh it's disgusting i
can't breathe
there's a brook somewhere that won't
stop babbling shut up
sweetheart just hold tight and i'll be
there
well april is right here and i
am down here somewhere
[Music]
hello andy you have to save me i'm
camping with people i work with
hello april hello walk around in circles
like i am
help triangulate the phone call
hello hang on i'm gonna try to get to
higher ground
ah wow i found some thorns
where's jake did you eat him terry no
good morning guys
how'd you get out of the pit easy peasy
lemon squeezy
actually it took me hours i tied all my
clothes together tethered them to a log
and used it as a grappling hook
managed to snag it in a root aren't you
freezing not at all
mainly because my skin is on fire from
all the poison ivy in this tree
you know i just realized this is pam's
and my first night away together
i used to play it over my head and it
was just a little bit different
maybe a nice hotel or a romantic dinner
wine um but wine that wasn't made out of
beets
didn't think dwight would be involved at
all and uh
i always imagine less manure you need to
spread it i mean some manure
just it's going to work less this is
beet food
moe's what are you doing no most put the
put the manure down
put it down do not throw it out
you